good morning Hank it's supposed to be
Monday but in fact it's Saturday Hank
that's Tobin Anderson world famous
children's book author and winner of the
2006 National Book Award this is the
guide some quick background information
before Tobin and I met up at a Book
Festival in Kalamazoo
Tobin spent a day in Detroit looking at
abandoned buildings where he randomly
met our tour guide when we tried to fly
back to the east on Friday our flights
got canceled so we called the guide up
and he offered to take us on an urban
exploring tour through the ruins of
Detroit as you will see the guide is
something of a genius
we made a filling that can be seen from
the Oh miles away that made an
impression on people that didn't just
blend in and step out Hank that's the
Eastern wig and hair company we're gonna
go in it I think but not not in the
traditional way
okay so that didn't work Hank and I'll
tell you why how the owner of the
building happened to drive by while
Tobin was pulling down the fire escape
Hank I'm in an abandoned building I'm
feeling some anxiety I'm a question of
abandonment yes I wonder why there are
so many lights on that means it could be
a caretaker you know it could come on
and check out I mean not every day I
think I think it goes without saying
that you shouldn't break into abandoned
buildings particularly not unless you
have professional assistance like we did
it's unsafe asbestos e terrifying and
generally illegal is it a happy place
Tobin does it feel safe Tobin
someone in here has played repeated
games of tic-tac-toe in clearly the O's
have mad skills we heard people walking
around we heard people talking we had to
flee you can tell which one's anxiety
from the fact that the camera is
shuttering like a like a dove giving
birth okay I see Howard cream in a
Spanish I'm using the camera light to
see where I'm going
everything is covered in ice it's just
layers and layers of rubble I think once
I got past the anxiety of being
someplace I shouldn't be I started to
think about the ruins themselves the
eerie beauty of the ice encrusted decay
to the tour guide the ruins seemed to
represent a failure a failure to
recognize and use the gifts of the past
- Tobin they also spoke of the
inevitability of it all this stark
reminder that one day every building
will be ruins I felt a mix of anxiety
and reverence that I haven't felt since
I worked at the hospital I kept slipping
up and calling it the cathedral instead
of the theater I'm on the stage dear sir
dear Z so it's
in favilla teste ahead of whom Sibylla
National Geographic from 1968 Iran's
shah crowns himself in glittering tehran
it was a very different time it's heavy
huh look at all these safe-deposit boxes
alright first we have to go to the
control hole again hey just came through
a hole in that fence theater and then
into this office building I think this
is what the theater used to look like
that we were in today that's decayed
beyond recognition for the most part hey
Hank tell me if this place looks
familiar